[موسيقى]
دار الاوبرا السلطانيه تحفه معماريه
تحتضنها العاصمه العمانيه مسقط مبناها
يتكون من ثمانيه طوابق منها ثلاثه تقع تحت
الارض وخمسه فوقها يتناغم تصميمها
المعماري مع التراث العماني والعربي
والاسلامي في عهود مختلفه وتقع على مساحه
تتجاوزوا 80 الف متر مربع
[موسيقى]
على هذا المسرح الذي يتسعوا لاكثر من الف
شخص عزف وتغني اشهر الفنانين العالميين
والعرب ابرزهم فنان العرب محمد عبده
القيصر كاظم الساهر امال ماهر وغيرهم
الكثير ومع احتفال دار الاوبرا السلطانيه
بمرور عشر سنوات على افتتاحها ينتظر
الجمهور في السلطنه باقه من العروض
والحفلات خلال الفتره الملكيه
[موسيقى]
دار الاوبرا السلطانيه تضم اكثر من 50
محلا تجاريا ما بين مقاهي ومطاعم
ومتاجر
تتنوعوا انشطتها ومجالاتها
اضافه مختلفه
لتجربه الزائر
[موسيقى]
والمجوهرات وغيرها من ابرز مبيعات محل
الاوبرا جاليريا الذي ياتي على شكل رواق
يداخم مبنى دار الاوبرا السلطانيه
تعمل شيء هيك انت بتعمل حسب اذا في اشياء
احداث حلوه تحضرها حسب انت وذوقك يعني
فايندزت فكره المتاجر بجانب الاوبرا جيدا
من المناسب ان تتناول وجبات الطعام او
التسوق قبل الذهاب الى الابيض
وانصح دائما السياحه بزياره هذا المكان
المطاعم والمقاهم هنا تعكس ثقافه وتاريخ
السلطنه يجب على اي شخص يزور مسقط ان ياتي
الى الاوبرا السلطانيه
مبنى دار الاوبرا السلطانيه يعتبر من
المباني متعدده الاستخدامات حيث يمكنه ان
يستضيف فعاليات مختلفه كحفلات الاوبرا
والحفلات الموسيقيه والمسرحيه الى جانب
المؤتمرات والعديدي من الملتقيات الثقافيه
والفنيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي من العاصمه
العمانيه مسقط العربيه
[موسيقى]